old anymore that's the sort of behavior
expect from my doors when they were 11
but it's for him to choose how he
decides to treat and there are serious
issues that we were to raise with the
President of the USA yes of course
they're our closest allies we have a
special relationship with them I compare
it to having a best friend our
expectations of our best friend are much
higher than they are an acquaintance or
just as a friend and I've got
differences we should be able to express
them honestly and candidly and my
frustration with our Prime Minister and
our government is this weakness and
inability to share some of the concerns
we've got with Donald Trump if they are
playground antics as you say why do you
why do you engage with him well this all
began and you'll remember this little
began when Donald Trump was running to
be the president and he said he wanted
to ban Muslims from entering to the USA
but I'll make an exception for the
Muslim Mayor of London Sadiq Khan the
point I made and I did it in a courteous
manners look there's nothing exceptional
about me don't make an exception for me
I think your ban is a bad idea
there are lots of Muslims not just in
America who love being American and are
proud to be Muslims but around the world
who love America and actually you've
claimed the hands of those extremists
who say Islam and the West are
incompatible and that led to him going
off on Twitter rants and saying beastly
things about me the point I was trying
to make in advance of his trip is we
have an opportunity to influence our
closest ally on some of the things we
disagree with him about I'll just give
you some examples of her may we just
through them surely about his policy to
ban Muslims from certain countries
surely disagree with his policy to
separate children from their parents on
the Mexican border surely we think it's
wrong when he amplifies the tweets from
racists in this country and surely we
should be saying listen you know you do
realize you're a poster boy for the
far-right movement around the wall from
Hungary to Italy France to the UK and
also she was saying you know what we
think we faced a climate emergency we
think you made a mistake walking
away from the Paris climate change
Accord will you think about coming back
can we persuade you to come back I could
go on and my point is Teresa may is so
weak as a prime minister and our
government is so scared that it wouldn't
say boo to a goose and I think that's
wrong our values aren't reflected by
this prime minister we should be saying
it to him but we need some would say
that you need him to be on side
especially after brexit so why don't you
bury the hatchet why are you still
embarking in you know chewing and
throwing with him on Twitter why weren't
you at the state banquet last night well
I'm very happy to meet with Donald Trump
I've always said it's right and proper
for there to be a good working
relationship between our country in the
USA he should come here not in a state
visit and there should be a state
banquet and there should be the wrong
out of the red carpet that's an honor
bestowed on very few presidents only two
I think I've had that honor bestowed
upon them and I think the point I've
made well the two Bush and Obama
Ashleigh Clinton didn't have a state
business that's by the by the point
Billis he's been present for two years
and yes of course he should be here
commemorating the d-day 75 years ago
with the the Canadians are here New
Zealand's here Australia's here of
course we should commemorate the d-day
landings what are the things those brave
men and women fought for is for us to
have religious freedoms they fought for
equality look I can't be silent when
there's a rolling back of women's
reproductive rights in America I can't
be silent when lgbtq+ rights have been
rolled back in America I can't be silent
when the president of these free world
is defending white supremacist neo Nazis
and as he sea mites in Charlotte's well
I just can't be silent when he amplifies
the tweets of racists in this country I
mean and I'm embarrassed that our Prime
Minister isn't one to say boo to a goose
so the thing to do is engage rather than
snob
I'm very happy to I'm very happy to
engage it a lot I've offered to meet
with Donald Trump's take him around our
wonderful city to show him the strengths
of diversity I'm celebrating e today to
show him at the mosque of London where
there are proud Londoners proud Brits
but also comfortable with being a Muslim
as well I just come from the migration
Museum in Saffron and where you can see
the benefits to our city in that country
of migration economically socially and
culturally by the way America is also
benefited from migrations or I'm really
happy to meet with Donald Trump
I've not resorted to silly name-calling
are using Twitter in that manner and by
the way if the President of the USA gets
wound up by the Mayor of London god only
knows what will happen if the leader of
North Korea or Iran trying to try and
why now and I'm not trying to do that
but you know that he loves the pomp and
circumstance we all know that you know
he likes having his ego massage no
better way than to offer him a state
visit so that he can have face time with
her majesty perhaps even fist bumping
we're not sure whether he did that or
not that's open to speculation but if
that means we get a good trade deal
surely you just need to hold your nose
and let it happen can I just tell you
this that there are people in Hungary
Italy France in this country as well who
a few years ago their views were on the
fringe their far-right extremists their
views are now mainstream and they'd been
normalized because of Donald Trump
Donald Trump is the poster boy for the
far-right movement and us given him even
more credibility I think as a mistake I
think in years to come by the way we're
going to regret given this state visit
to Donald Trump and what sort of message
does it send to friends in Hungary in
Italy in France and elsewhere and all
around the Western world where they've
seen a rise of nativist populist
movements and Donald Trump is seen as
the leader of this far-right movement
his former campaign manager is going
around the world teaching extremist
movements how to become normalized and
mainstream are we really gonna stay
silent about this
but but mr. Mehra if I may your
responsibility is to the people of
London and that includes the business
leaders of London and they need a good
deal with the United States when we pull
out a brexit and so as a result we need
to roll out the red carpet not only here
in Downing Street but also over at
Buckingham Palace for the President of
the United States if that's what it
takes
well let me tell you basis two Americans
businesses tourists students who come to
our city and enrich our city there's
wonderful businesses in London which are
American businesses and similarly
wonderful Londoners to go to America and
contribute to America as well of course
when a good trade deal with America
we've got a pretty good deal now as
members of the European Union all I'd
say respectfully to our government is be
careful accepting the advice from this
president to walk away from the EU
without a deal expecting a fantastic
trade deal with the US so we heard this
Sunday from the ambassador you referred
to him he was talking this Sunday about
sort of trade deal the Americans what is
US private firms running the NHS the
sort of trade deal America wants is
their chicken and their beef being
accessible in our country when we know
the standards are very different to
America what's what they are - and I
kind of so a good deal for America it's
not necessarily good deal fast but I'll
be very unwise
I'd advise caution expecting a good deal
with America on the basis for what
Donald Trump said yesterday final
question to you mr. mayor if I may you
talked about mr. Trump being petty why
do you allow them to fly that baby blimp
you know it's offensive and it's gonna
upset him the key thing in relation to
any blimp by there's been a blimp phone
about me a phone of me as well is they
look it's got to be peaceful it's got to
be safe and it's got to be lawful one of
the great things about our countries the
rights we have in relation to freedom
expression the right to protest but it's
gonna be safe peaceful and lawful I
can't be a censor to decide what is what
it's tasteful and what is no I grew up
what you spit an image
well we saw politicians really respects
politicians
having fun made about them there was a
blimp of me wearing a yellow bikini my
only criticism was Red's my color not
yellow